How Do You Find the Percentage of a Given
Quantity I Mean Something Like What is 10
Per Off 30 We Go Step by Step to
Understand This First Let's Look at 10 Per
We Can Write 10 Per S 10 Ba
100 10 Parts Out of
100 of Means  Multiplied by and we write
30 as is 10 out of 10 e 100 and 10 out of 3 e 30
so this equals 3 so 10 out of 30 is 3 but what does this exactly mean Let's
understand this with an example what it
actually means is 3 out
of 30  Parts Equals
10 I've had at least 25 of them have been lying around for
too long and are rotten So how
many mangoes are rotten 25 of them 8 mangoes are
no good How much is that's what we do
in this case Let's see the total  Number of mangoes
is 8 and it says that 25 of the total mangoes are
unfit for constant are
written We use the same technique as we used here we
write 25 as
25/1 of as multiply by and 8 as is so
all we have to do  Is Find
25/1 Malla Ba 8 25 Ta 4 E 100 And 4 Ta 2
E 8 So This Equals 2 So We Can Say That To
Mango Out Of The At Are Ruton
[Music]
B